do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad arshad Muhammad arshad has
helped develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course I
definitely recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now
guys hope you guys are winning Charlotte
I'm here with the champion the one and
only uh hijabi right
you heard him that came out his mouth
nowhere else sober sisters we're here
with uh how you been long time no see
alhamdulillah you show me the World Cup
pundit I'm gonna call you big things
let's watch this video of this reporter
who claims to be from Fox News we don't
know whether it's not affirmed just had
to go through a essential date
for ladies
somehow I don't feel that specialist
you know we've got the propaganda off
the West uh sadly you know they're
trying to come and give us the you know
high moral values that they live by you
know very moral life they'll live by you
know Spanish and I give the analogy the
analogy you know subpano it's like you
have a name imagine you have a neighbor
so you you are a traditional uh a a
family imagine you living here you might
be Christian you might be Jewish you
might be Hindu you might be sick you
might be a Muslim Traditional Values you
follow you're here with your wife and
kids yeah whatever I'm trying to say and
your next neighbor is just an immoral
living lifestyle of individuals the dad
is somebody who kills people is a
murderer
yeah Sun Sun is a drug leader okay like
Pablo Escobar and then you've got the
daughter and the mother who are
selling this or for sex and all that
kind of stuff yeah and then you're like
okay no problem look you live your life
I live my life okay you want to do your
thing okay that's fine just leave me be
but they come knocking on your door one
day and they go hey you go why do you
why don't you live like us and you're
like well hold on a second man all this
time I've been putting up with you know
you want to do your thing to you your
religion do you meet mine carry on but
now you come into my door and trying to
question my way of lifestyle with your
way of lifestyle this is exactly what we
saw in this video Yeah you could have
just used the shorter example though
what's that that was very long-winded
show me a short one just say that I go
to my neighbor yes with something I
can't prove and I force it upon them
that was all dead which one do you guys
like my one or this one you guys decide
some reason
feel that special
why would a woman a western woman who
goes to these countries where they have
Traditional Values don't feel special
I think she doesn't feel special because
she wants to if she just goes through a
what would you call it unisex when it's
boss yeah yeah go through a unisex one
where a man's there and he's gonna touch
her all over yeah and make sure that she
hasn't smuggled anything and she has
explosives oh yeah check her in the
cracks and crevices and obviously she
that makes her feel more special
apparently okay how else can they they
feel more special well when they take
her into the booth and you know check
even more using their gloves and you
know oh strip search I didn't say that
you said that no no because you have to
if they're carrying something so I'm
sure she we should be okay with a man
doing searching her strip naked you know
yeah I mean you have to you know really
be invasive to be special because she
wants to be special so um maybe she
feels special when she's walking down
the road and 90 of the woman in the UK
get sexually harassed do you think maybe
she's talking about that kind of
specialty
I don't think I think it's good that
you've reminded her of that because I
don't think she that's in her kind of
mentality because she's brainwashed by
the Western media that again people that
have gone there yeah and they've
witnessed Qatari
um Hospitality they've said that the
Western media is is lying and they're
clutching at straws that was the word
that was used and it was aired by GB
news exactly well a GPU is a bit yeah
they said they are clutching at straws
so this reporter is exactly doing that I
mean it's just like the indoctrination
that a woman would have a problem with
this segregation of females entering one
way on obviously you have to be searched
and that she has a problem with it she's
like I feel really special
it's the indoctrination it's reached
such a level the Pinnacle which is that
you would rather be sexually objectified
men coming and trying it on with you
touching you up flirting with you using
sexual words harassing you and I mean
let's be honest the Western world is
indulged in this now it doesn't mean the
Western world is saying that this is
okay yeah but they're indulging even so
much so that now in the workplace and
you have to keep the door open you know
they're getting a bit muslimic on us
yeah so but you can see that the level
brothers and sisters that these women
sadly they feel that if you don't look
at them if you lower your gaze you don't
treat them special if you don't you know
maybe when you're talking to them you
know put your arm around them you don't
make them feel special and I'm like wow
you sexually objectify yourself and then
when men sexually objectify you you are
not happy but when you go to a Islamic
country who has Traditional Values and
they don't want to sexually objectify
you even though you sexually objectify
yourself and they choose to be
respectful you feel odd you know what's
odd the odd here is yourself not the
people in that country you have been
brought up in such an odd way that you
think if people don't conform to your
way of living it's abnormal and that's
why I saw in the face she was like this
is abnormal and I don't blame it yeah
because she was not treated especially
yeah and also she's one of and fact
she's one of many that will be allowed
into the stadium yeah she'll be allowed
in the stadium they're not stopping her
from going into the stadium they're just
separating the men and the women however
if she wore a hijab and she was entering
a school in India and in France she will
be told to remove that piece of clothing
she'll be told to show her body yeah
just so she can go and sit an exam or
just so she can go inside and become
educated just let that sink in for a
while here you're just going into a
stadium but in France in possibly
Denmark they've banned the hijab as well
in India who did this was everywhere all
over social media were young girls were
going to sit their exams and they were
told to remove clothing just so they can
go in and sit the exam wow Ali you've
made a big mistake it's a hug I think
we're gonna have to delete this video we
can't we have to put it up no no you
know why yeah we've made a big big
mistake tell me because you've assumed
that she's saying that there's separate
entrances for male and female but she
hasn't asked their pronouns exactly
actually if she's a man
she hasn't maybe that's why she's not
feel special
in fact she's saying separate entrances
for male and female how would she Define
male and female that's a big insult to
the lgbtq community yes so are you
trying to say that the woman standing
there actually woman
are you trying to say that you are a
woman maybe you're a man maybe everyone
at that gate might be a man
No in fact it's not even man it's CIS
male actually Ali yes I find that
offensive as well to be honest I'm sorry
yeah you said you said did you just did
you what did you call me I called you
Ali who said I'm Ali
I fed into that one didn't I who said
what do you mean by fell what do you
mean by in what do you mean by two oh
you've gone Jordan Peterson on me what
do you mean by me oh damn what do you
mean by damn
what do you mean by
until next time
what do you mean by that
Allah